welcome back to las vegas now we know
that staying healthy is mostly about
what you eat and how you eat
and the holidays can slow down those
healthy eating habits but they don't
have to registered dietitian mia sin
shares some recipes
for healthier holiday meals hey las
vegas
now the holiday season is officially
here i have some
festive meal ideas and recipes for your
healthier holiday gatherings
starting with a protein and produce
platter pairing protein with produce is
the perfect snacking starter to a
holiday meal that won't ruin your
appetite and taste
even better than it looks get creative
with different fresh produce options
like grapes and figs
next add protein i'm adding pecans and
two types of wisconsin cheeses
wisconsin is the state of cheese they
win more awards for their cheese than
anywhere else in the world
you can find perfect cheese pairings and
recipe inspiration at
wisconsincheese.com
next every healthier holiday menu needs
veggie dishes
brussels sprouts and sweet potatoes are
in season and taste great roasted which
brings out their natural sweetness
research shows that in season produce
typically tastes the best
is most nutritious and affordable i'm
tossing with the very brand cooking oil
which is a professional grade cooking
oil with a high smoke point
specifically designed for high heat
cooking it has 10 grams of omega-9 fatty
acids per serving
and is non-gmo certified you can find it
exclusively at verycookingoil.com
it also has a neutral flavor so it
allows the flavor of your veggies and
seasonings to shine through
next we have a festive side dish or meal
that you can make with your thanksgiving
leftovers
this fall wild rice dish is made with in
season veggies
nuts and seeds dried cranberries and the
lundberg family farms organic wild blend
rice
that mixes the rich and full-bodied
savory flavors of black brown red and
wild rice
this rice blend is a classic for holiday
dishes both beautiful
and versatile adding a gourmet look
simply toss together your rice with
roasted sweet potato brussels sprouts
pecans pepitas dried cranberries and
leftover turkey
finally i have a better for you dessert
that's single serve and customizable
these are six ingredient crisps in
blueberry strawberry and apple topped
with wonder creamery cork
this european style cultured dairy
staple has a non-tart flavor with
buttery notes
a thick creamy texture and is high in
protein calcium and probiotics which are
beneficial bacteria that support
digestion and immune health to make
simply add your fruit of choice to a
pre-greased oven-safe skillet
and bake for 10 minutes at 350 degrees
fahrenheit mix together a fourth cup of
blanched almond flour
1 teaspoon of cinnamon 1 tablespoon of
maple syrup
and 1 tablespoon of oil crumble on top
of your fruit and bake for another 10
minutes
then top with your wonder creamery cork
now i hope you enjoyed all of these
healthier holiday recipes you can find
them at my website nutritionbymia.com
and nutritionbymia on instagram where i
also share
meal ideas and nutrition tips daily